people are really good
at copying each other's faces
in fact we're the best
but dogs pay attention to facial expressions
gorillas and orangutangs even copy those expressions
it's been thought though that this attention to faces
and copying of facial expressions
was a feature of social creatures
now researchers have shown that sun bears
can also copy each other's facial expressions exactly
something only ever seen before in primates
scientists studied a group of 22 bears
living together at the Bornean sun bear conservation center
they recorded hundreds of voluntary play sessions
between different pairs of bears
and found the bears made two distinct
open-mouthed facial expressions
in one the bear simply opens its mouth
in the other the bear opens its mouth while
wrinkling its nose and baring its top teeth
having two different facial expressions
allow the researchers to judge whether the bears
were mimicking their partners faces exactly
if the bears only made one face it would be
impossible to tell whether the expression was being
passed from bear to bear or if it was just a face
that bears made while playing
the videos revealed that 13 of the 22 bears copied their
playmates facial expression exactly
within a second of seeing it
the researchers were surprised to find exact
facial mimicry in sun bears because the
bears don't have much of a social life in the wild
the bears also showed what's called "social sensitivity"
or the ability to sense the attention of others—
85% of the time that a bear was making a face
another bear had a front-row seat
finding such sophisticated communication in the
antisocial sun bear makes the authors
think facial mimicry might be more
common than previously thought
it also suggests that social skills
like communication can be useful adaptations
even for animals with seemingly simple social lives
now what the bears are actually communicating to one
nother there's not much data on that yet but
one guess would be "let's keep playing"